from highs within Heist to shocking
betrayals we're here to entangle the
series many complex nuts this is the
ending of Kaleidoscope season one
explained episodes of Netflix's dazzling
Heist drama Kaleidoscope can be viewed
in any order apart from whites which
should always be watched last while the
show's non-linear format initially seems
like just a cool gimmick it soon reveals
itself To Be An Elegant feat of
Storytelling luckily Kaleidoscope isn't
likely to be one last job for its makers
and it's certainly far from their first
Show creator Eric Garcia wrote the novel
Majestic man which was adopted into the
2003 movie of the same name that film
was directed by Ridley Scott who serves
as an executive producer on Kaleidoscope
notably Matchstick Men which stars
Nicholas Cage and Alison Lowman as a
father-daughter con artist Duo plays
tricks on his characters and the
audience to entertaining and emotional
effects obviously this is more than a
little reminiscent of Kaleidoscope
Garcia and scars aren't the only
intriguing figures involved in
Kaleidoscope leading man ray Vernon is
fantastically played by Giancarlo
Esposito as elegant criminal mastermind
Gus Fringe on better call soul and
Breaking Bad he works hard to protect a
super secure underground lair rather
than breach one on the opposite end of
the show's core sheet as Max Casella who
stars in the pink episode A small time
Crook and Big Time Podcast therapy fan
Taco who steals just about every scene
he's in
is played by Peter Mark Kendall is a
Smuggler who loves to find the things in
life and lacks a taste for personal
growth or even basic Heist hygiene more
than one stands distractible dreamy
nature leads to ruin for the crew most
notably he leaves his hipster glasses at
the scene of the crime and makes a
getaway in a car with easily traceable
vanity plates though he's one of the
League's violent members of the crew
Stan indirectly spills his share of
blood Carlos takes outstand's mother and
wife and Stan Dodges the feds when they
take down Bob by the end of Kaleidoscope
Stannis also butchered any chance he
once had to learn from his mistakes
still he lives to try another day and
stuff his face with tacos when he
realizes Judy has likely taken the Money
and Run
a Ben lawyer who moonlights his offense
Ava Mercer is Agent nazana varsi's white
whale to protect Ray after he escapes
from prison Ava notifies the FBI that
narzan is using drugs on the job this
cost nasaan custody of her kids and
kick-starts her quest for revenge
against Ava narzan's obsession with Ava
and Rey comes to a fatal head in pink
and dead ends in whites Ava's motives
aren't always entirely clear outside of
her fondness for Ray her grandmother and
the High Life meanwhile narzan's
obsession with tying Ava and Rey to the
diamond way Heist and the SLS job is
simple the lady wants revenge ultimately
narzan gets a version of this as Ava is
killed in a shootout after a bitter
fight for her life but narzan doesn't
live long enough to enjoy it as Roger
warns Hannah and yellow the triplets
take narzan down by sending a Lackey to
take her out in the street she dies a
few steps later this is just another way
Kaleidoscope drives home the idea that
chasing white whales only leads to death
by drowning Bob and Judy Goodwin's Story
shows how hard it is to escape a toxic
romance and the life of crime
essentially Bob is fire judious gasoline
and together they burn down any trust
left among the crew on the night of the
heist this comes to a head when Bob
attempts to steal the full 7 billion for
them and take out the rest of the team
he did the right thing okay okay well
Judy appears to end her relationship
with Bob and white by seemingly killing
him to save Stan we see her heart still
belongs to him in pink Kaleidoscope
knows old habits don't just die hard
they die twice Bob meets an end that
awaits so many fueled by jealousy one he
could have avoided by going to therapy
before he sat on a one-way path to
bleeding out on the beach
though RJ is great with mechanics and
music the crew's getaway driver doesn't
have much to do aside from making the
occasional funny comment and shooting
Bob in the buttock despite having a
sweet winning energy RJ still loses Big
Time crime isn't in RJ's nature but he
fights to prove himself to Rey and the
crew one of the central questions
Kaleidoscope asks is whether anyone can
really change and if it's worth it RJ
changes from a fairly good dude to a
hardened Criminal by drawing a gun on
Bob however he can't quite make the
tough guy transition stick especially
since RJ's trying to protect Judy who
kills him to protect Bob ultimately he's
just too good for the Heist game and way
too bad at playing it on a happier note
Hannah's sister Liz survives the
emotional ending of Kaleidoscope like RJ
we don't know much about Liz but we know
she's comfortable enough with crime to
manage to keep her nose clean however RJ
might have gotten off easy if Liz traded
her life of leisure for a life of
helping Hannah manage to Triple its
wealth with cheekbones that good Roger
has got to be bad most episodes portray
Roger as a well-heeled and respected
creator of the world's safest safe but
that couldn't be further from the truth
Roger is the latest long card pulled by
Ray Vernon's former partner in crime
Graham Davies if Rey's story explores
how poisonous the life fueled by Revenge
can be Rogers is a cautionary tale
confirming there's no rest for the
wicked though Roger enjoys the High Life
he's always looking over his shoulder
even before Leo and his crew arrive on
the scene Roger admits to Ray that he
isn't sure he could have saved Lily he
tells Hannah that Loyalty means nothing
to him but there's something Bittersweet
in just how much he protests against
connection while also blatantly seeking
him bird says his wife leaves him and he
loses his son to what may one day be a
murder charge it's easy to see his
treasure for what it is and that's
Fool's Gold Hannah is Rey's daughter and
Leo's greatest Protege she's warm
intelligent and unscrutable when it
comes to where her Allegiance lies until
pink that is when she reveals to her
father that she took the take and
switched to bearer bonds with copy paper
cynics will say Hannah plays her dad to
save her own neck from the triplets
however her heartfelt admission to raid
makes it clear that she pulls the Khan
to save her dad from himself by
switching the bonds out before the crew
can make off with them she protects the
evil Trio's fortune and buys back her
dad's safety she also manages to
purchase a super sweet Mansion to live
in with her baby and Ava's dogs Hannah
breaks the family cycle of self-sabotage
bonds with her estranged dad and seems
to be the only member of the
Kaleidoscope Heist crew to come out on
top I'm not Roger
and I'm not your Inside Man it all seems
peachy until you consider the
international bad guys who now run
Hannah's life and the fact that her dad
is likely murdered by Roger's kid if
these sobering realities don't take the
sweetness out of that Seaside Mansion we
don't know what will
the side criminals of Kaleidoscope
aren't exactly gentleman thieves like
Rey but they are horrifying horsey and
hilarious plus it all means absolutely
awful ends that illustrates a key
Kaleidoscope theme basically if you do
crime long enough you'll definitely take
a fall Carlos has Roger's right-hand man
ready to throw hands and guns whenever
the need arises though this Hitman picks
off his fair share of lives he beats his
Bitter End in red then there's Andrew a
former employee of Rogers who is framed
by Hannah and engages in his own crimes
of extortion after Roger fires him
Kaleidoscope demonstrates that greed is
definitely not good many times over
especially when cocky Andrew overplays
his hand and gets a plastic bag to the
head for his trouble perhaps the most
memorable side criminals of all other
therapy podcast loving taco and cardigan
rocking Samson this dynamic duo provides
a brief but potent shot of belly
laughter alongside their Bloodshed
during their brief time on screen
Kaleidoscope is about Cycles whether
it's a turn of the screw the tumble of
locks or the spin on the titular
Kaleidoscope these characters Circle the
truth of themselves through each choice
they make then endure the full circle
consequences and occasionally the
benefits at the center of these
overlapping Cycles is Ray Vernon Alias
Leo Pap Cycles are nearly impossible to
break and raise a foremost symbol of
this theme many episodes are framed by
his attempts to express to Hannah why
he's done what he's done and why so much
of it is motivated by his desire to
change or at least to redeem himself
it's never been about the money for Rey
instead it's about revenge which he gets
at a grave cost when the one silver
lining of your perfect Heist is that
your daughter heisted it out from under
you to save your life it's a sign that
times are hard Rey loses a lot over the
course of Kaleidoscope from the bonds to
his crew to Ava and ultimately his own
life yet he still wins he may be driven
to exact revenge on Roger for not saving
Lily a Revenge he achieves by stashing
the club Jewel in Roger's private Vault
but his true Bounty is Hannah's
forgiveness and acceptance as the crew
sails away from Manhattan and into a
bleak future in red ray says no one can
pinpoint the exact moment in our fell
apart the heist goes off perfectly but
afterward everything goes sideways
indeed a kaleidoscope gives its crew
plenty of opportunities to suffer and
shine seeing our Master criminals at
their best and worst creates an
intriguing energy as Creator Eric Garcia
told the New York Post he drew influence
from many Classic Movies including
rafifi and Pulp Fiction like rafifi
white showcases are largely non-verbal
and very intricate High sequence the
first line spoken comes when Stan speaks
after several complex steps saying
well that was easy
Kaleidoscope also delivers its own
contributions to the highest Hall of
Fame including Judy's press-on nails SIM
card handoff and the sweetly comic
destruction of dosing the prison mess
with magic mushrooms best of all it's a
moment when Hannah Heiser died in a
niece and while intentions double cross
he doesn't anticipate the show doesn't
indicate this until the very last moment
which turns feelings of deception into
the pure delight of seeing an excellent
magic trick pulled off we may have made
a little change to the plan Obsession
Revenge trust and family loyalty feel
the series and packets of the brim with
emotional heat the biggest weapon in his
Arsenal is a double-barreled shotgun of
Revenge and regrets because of the
Kaleidoscope nature of the show's
storytelling we get to see as many
characters shift throughout time they
change dramatically creating a vivid
portrait of their motivations
maintaining entertainment and emotional
resonance at the same time is hard to
pull off it's an even need to trick to
balance these two forces while creating
a show that can reportedly be watched
more than 5000 different ways in a sense
pulling this off is pulling off a
magnificent Heist while telling a story
about Heist if a big flashy high-centric
TV show can definitely tackle
destructive cycles and speakable trauma
and a difficult healing process there
may be hope for streaming media yet
[Music]